jetzt will verwendet handy titel
eingeblendet jubel und ich mache heute
einen lügendetektor challenge das ist
dieses gerät in hirn und das sagt obmann
lügt oder nicht ich weiß nicht wie das
gelegt dass raus wenn nicht hier sind
fünf sensoren wahrscheinlich dass durch
die finanzämter oder ich weiß nicht ob
es sogar so feuchtigkeit an den händen
ich glaube so krass geht's nicht auf
jeden fall gibt es bei diesem gerät zwei
mond- und ich bin ganz ehrlich es gibt
einmal einen branchen mode und einen
elektrizitäts mode wir nehmen für heute
den vibrations- modus weil wir haben
beide erstmal keinen kopf auf einen
elektroschock du dich an deine schlechte
erfahrungen mit elektroschocks gemacht
bei mir war es so dass ich auf einer
kuhwiese war über einen zaun gesprungen
bin hängen geblieben bin und ganz viele
shops bekommen habt die für kühe
ausgerichtet waren der juli war das
gleich mit einem wertvollen pferde
elektroschock der kann ein mensch schon
richtig die haare zu berge stehen lassen
jeden fall habe ich mir dieses gerät
bestellt und in der umkleide skala ley
und truth also welche wetten gleiche er
abwechslung gehabt darauf stellen wir
haben für uns beide gegenseitig zehn
fragen vorbereitet die man beantworten
muss also was wärst du hast du schon mal
geraucht hast du schon mal was geklaut
keine ahnung und dann werden wir unsere
hand hier drauf legen in die antwort
sagen und dann wird uns dieses gerät
sagen ob man lügt oder nicht und damit
geht es jetzt los dass der elektromotor
dass der branchen know how der branchen
mode sagt uns jetzt erstmal quasi nur ob
die lügen oder ob wir die wahrheit
erzählen wenn ihr bock drauf habe dass
wir nochmal den
elektroschock modus demnächst macht und
dass man leider und schreibt und in die
kommentare und wird sagen dass frage
hast du heute generell schon unabhängig
jetzt nämlich kilo gehör letzte mal
gelesen dass der mensch oft am tag
erste frage die ich für juli vorbereitet
habe hast du schon mal in einen wald
gepinkelt
ja ja ich hab das ja so eine typische
frage sagt nein
[Musik]
wo hast du nen waldwinkel denkst du bist
denn schwester definitiv
hundertprozentig die hat es war ein
besseres ab aber das hey hey bin nicht
sarah werde das ist einfach dumm wie
brot diese frage an dich meine liebe
freundin hast du angst alleine zu sein
neuester film vibration ok dafür ein
bisschen komisch
julia hat auf jeden fall heftige angst
allein und hat das auch zugegeben und
dieses gerät hat wir sagen das gelogen
aber vielleicht hast du einfach die cd
war es in dem bericht
denken muss das wenn du mal wieder
alleine bist hast du einzahlungen
[Musik]
nein dunkel das ist genauso wie helle
nur dunkel
genau das ist nicht mehr ich habe
wirklich nicht sogar angst im dunkeln
es kommt auf den worten wenn ich einen
ort und helen keller und dann bin ich in
dem gleichen ort im dunkeln zu dann ist
es überhaupt nicht schlimm so keller
oder irgendwie meiner wohnung oder keine
ahnung wo aber wenn ich jetzt halt da
haben jedoch hey du bist in neuenstadt
und läuft jetzt gerade dadurch nicht
durch den wald oder so dann vielleicht
ein bisschen hast du schon mal etwas
teurer als zehn euro geklaut gar nicht
ich bin ja 2
aber er hat ja nicht wahr ich mache
meinen namen will ich meine zweifel
haben als erste daran das ok dem weil
ich jetzt nicht so ich weiß ich kenne
die meinen zweiten haben schreibt
zweiten in die kommentare doch als sie
noch kennen sollte also den namen luca
habe ich früher überhaupt nicht gemocht
das ist richtig das wirklich richtig
weil früher habe ich ein mädchen was
auch luca nie so dass wir ein bisschen
komisch aber ich bin am luxembourg für
dich hier die nächste frage wären ja
vorhin ob du schon mal geklaut hat hast
du
mal auf hotels abgezogen
das ist jetzt neun jungen herzen lag und
ich hab nicht auf elektro machen ich
habe ihr und elektroschocker war
jetzt kann ja gar nicht sein hätte also
uns war es halt nicht wie viel ich habe
nichts umgestellt ich schwöre meine
nächste frage ist hast du schon mal ein
straßenschild gestohlen ein
straßenschild überhaupt überhaupt nicht
mehr so 3 hey da finde ich aber auch
nicht nicht ich stelle das zugeben ich
habe diesmal zurückgegeben bei mir waren
private schilder von zu kennzeichnen wo
sie kumpels von mir gesagt haben der
mich zurückgebracht und andere ja das
hab ich auch zurückgebracht die nächste
frage an dich manager jude ich hoffe
dass sie mich wieder der elektroschock
bekommen
wie gesagt wenn ihr wollt dass wir mal
komplett das mit elektroschock machen
lassen lag da steckt in die kommentare
100 der ganzen bekommen
diese waren nie freunde also juli auf
jeden fall wirklich nicht über dich sind
denke ich so die größten anti raucher
die es gibt auch wenn leute draußen
rauchen und wir auch wenn draußen auf
dem balkon rauchen dann fragt uns das
schon ab also juli nächste frage
es wird schon der nächste momentan
zufrieden
ja ich bin so wie ich sagte gerade zwei
drei sachen will ich nicht so mit
zufrieden jeder hat ja kleine
problemchen aber die merck schon freunde
wären es ist nicht so fragen gestellt
von wegen
ja also das ist halt einfach prinz
solche fragen finden
deswegen haben wir also standardfragen
erstmal genommen bist du froh ein
mädchen zu sein oder werden lieber einen
jungen
ähnlich die situation in dem ein junge
wird
von schenkst du lieber oder bekommen sie
lieber selbst geschenke ganz schwierig
kann ich hier keine antwort weil sie
nicht ich mache meine sache ich glaube
sagen ich verschenke wichtig liebe das
sachen zu verschenken ich finde
verschenken einfach mega ei so wenn man
selber weiß was drin ist aber dann wird
die spannung bei den anderen leuten
sieht das ganz cool
hast du dich schon mal verschuldet also
ernsthaft sagte gabriel
da kann ich jetzt nur was falsches sagen
ja ich hätte gedacht dass alle übrigen
also das ding ist ja auch das verstehen
vielleicht auch einige wie so richtig
beim 1
reaction auf jetzt videos von baby die
ich übrigens seit langer zeit nicht
gemacht habe weil ich ihren content
gerade wirklich einen sehr gut findet
aber das ist ja nie persönlich gemeinde
es ging nicht darum maxim konnte nicht
selbst gesagt nein aber die personen
habe ich jetzt nichts gegen kenne ich
halt eine nächste frage an
würdest du sagen dass du zuviel schläfst
nein wieso hast du denn die krasse musik
das war wieder elektrischen das war
wieder elektroschocker alle zehn finger
mal ist er wechselt der elektro betrieb
wechsel war beide male berlin erwartet
das ding ist das wirklich nicht
übermäßig viel steht oder sie ist
einfach übermäßig gemüse also übermäßig
krass müde bist du könntest den matsch
laufen die dinge mal irgendwo rum ist
mir einen hund schenken
ja also ich würde uns einen wunsch in
japan nun halten nicht jetzt gerade
baujahr voll auf die meinung dass solche
videos von golden retriever apis und so
und folglich ein kraftakt der wird sich
hier meine wohnung denn überhaupt noch
schöner den wahrscheinlichen fall sind
nicht immer denn wie soll ich den job
kennen wenn man noch erkennen dabei der
wir haben halt für den garten so jemand
wenn wir halten außer mit daten
vielleicht dann das helfen und die
letzte frage hier schon einige berühmte
bist du nachtragend
ich würde also nichts gegen dich aber
ich würde schon sagen dass bisschen
nachtragend ist bin halt auch übel
zusammentragen so dass htc familie meine
damen und herren wenn es euch gefallen
hatte das gerne mal ein leichter wie
gesagt wollt ihr dass wir das ganze mal
in diesem modus machen
judith ja immer schon in diesem video
jeden elektroschock bekommen nun scheint
es dass auf jeden fall gerne uns in die
kommentare können uns auch gerne fragen
und in die kommentare schreiben
die wir uns dann gegenseitig mal stellen
sollen dieses spiel natürlich kein
echter lügendetektor ist betitelt als
leidet act or aber kinderspielzeug ist
ein kinderspielzeug
[Musik]